people have just not made the commitment
to realizing brand is actually built in
social social by Nature allows you to
create more creative when you're able to
create more creative you're able to
focus on relevance not just awareness I
believe every Fortune 500 brand does not
have an awareness issue that's why
they're a Fortune 500 brand they have a
relevance issue how do you make Nike
matter to every single person how do you
make apple BMW product how do you make
it actually matter the way you make it
matter is by it's your third trip to
Dubai
why are you here and why do you care
about Dubai
um I'm here because
I want to build businesses and brand in
every part of the world
obviously
um some places are closer to Manhattan
and others so it's harder to get to Asia
or the Middle East than let's say Europe
yet I've been in Dubai more than I've
been to my own London office
in the last several years because I'm
incredibly bullish on the UAE I'm
bullish on the Middle East overall to be
frank and you know I I anticipate for
the next 50 years of my career as I wrap
up that those are all going to be 50
years of a lot of growth in the region
and I think a lot of that growth when
the history books write it
in Saudi in Egypt in in other parts of
the region a lot of it will link back to
the incredible foresight and aggressive
entrepreneurial and
cultural energy that Dubai brought to
the Middle East and so this is the
epicenter I think of what has started
this modern Middle East
and um it's clearly in a lot of ways the
most viable place for me to set up our
office
uh for the vaynerch Vayner world
and um
yeah I just want to Network and and
create opportunity
so when I met you in 2017 I was like one
of the things I one of the reasons I
wanted to meet you I'm like I wanted
vaynermedia to come to the Middle East
because I knew what you did back then no
one was doing and now obviously
marketing social has evolved so much you
talk a lot about brand being built in
Social what are some things that brands
of the Middle East should learn how to
do that you believe that they haven't
gotten it yet or even some in the U.S
yeah I mean I think like to your point
about what we've been talking about what
I've been talking about is
people have just not made the commitment
to realizing brand is actually built in
social social by Nature allows you to
create more creative
when you're able to create more creative
you're able to focus on relevance not
just awareness
I believe every Fortune 500 brand does
not have an awareness issue that's why
they're a Fortune 500 brand they have a
relevance issue how do you make Nike
matter to every single person how do you
make apple BMW product how do you make
it actually matter
the way you make it matter is by
storytelling the way you make it matter
is that story has to hit you me you
Dustin Meadow we have different things
that are going to make us interesting
social is conducive to that kind of
output plus we now live in a world where
the algorithms are rewarding content
that is interesting to people that by
Nature creates consumer insights
consumer insights are the starting point
to do great work
right if you know something about what
people are already interested in you
have a better chance
of making something that they're
interested in thus rendering them to do
the thing you want them to do and in the
context of this it means to buy
something so you know I think the brands
in the Middle East
and the world need to make a bigger
commitment to Output more volume more
platform strategy more creative strategy
more cultural strategy we call it packed
platforms and culture and I and I think
the faster they do that the more likely
they'll gain market share
um and I think every brand has to go
through that Journey
if it's that easy to do insights are
available in every single platform that
gives them data about what's happening
it's free doesn't cost anything to be on
any of these platforms why don't people
do it they don't know it's true
their advisors say hey their agencies
are not pushing it on them Brands don't
know how to keep them accountable the
conversation is not being had at scale
and so private Equity backed Brands
Venture Capital back Brands and
influencers and creators continue to do
this kind of work and they continue to
get leverage a market share uh and you
know I think at some point it will break
and you know
Hulu and Netflix were doing their thing
for years yelling about it but nobody
did anything about it and then there was
a Tipping Point and so I think there'll
be a Tipping Point in advertising and I
think we'll be the beneficiary of it
do you think the influencer game is over
game hasn't started really I do I think
that influencer marketing
Works incredibly well when it works and
that there's more work to be done and I
think it's a game that will forever play
out because now humans want to be famous
all of them every 13 year old in the
world wants to be a YouTuber wants to be
a tick-tocker and that means a lot of
them will try and many of them will be
successful not everyone's going to be
Logan Paul and Charlie demilio many of
them are going to end up being micro
influencers but if you're a micro
influencer and you can make seventy
thousand dollars a year talking about
pancakes or running shoes or skiing or
handbags well that might be a lot more
interesting than making seventy thousand
dollars a year being a lawyer or an
admin or being a copywriter and so I
think you're going to see the rise of
that and then as Brands figure that out
spending fifty thousand dollars to make
a video that nobody watches is a lot
less interesting than spending five
thousand dollars to get an influencer to
do something that you guaranteed people
are going to watch and so I think I
think we're just in the beginning of
influencer marketing I want to talk
about sports we didn't talk about it at
all this week in Dubai
um just athletes Brands entrepreneurship
a lot of people in the Middle East now
are paying attention to sports we see F1
in the region NBA is coming to the
region UFC's in the region wrestlers and
read why is sports going to be a really
good play for some brands for diplomacy
and for marketing and how has that
changed in the U.S
Sports is one of the True Religions of
our society
you know there's the religions we all
know and then there's music in sports
and fashion these are religions these
are passion points that are much deeper
than other passion points it's also real
life drama
you know we love we love drama it's why
we watch movies it's why we watch
content
uh Sports is the highest form of drama
it is the Ultimate Reality TV it's
actually real
uh you also have the greatest perf when
you have the greatest singers in the
world Chris Rock talked about this I
think in his stand-up right Beyonce is
not competing with a better another
great singer Rihanna and Beyonce aren't
trying to
knock each other off
but in sports you have the greatest
athletes trying to beat the greatest
athletes it's incompelling it is one of
the great engines for both diplomacy and
propaganda
and uh it will forever be that way and I
think people will continue to use Sports
as a catalyst to advance their
initiatives at a government level and
then on a human consumer level we will
continue to watch
uh and it might go from a man fighting a
lion to mix martial arts in a cage but
it will be always the same okay do's and
don'ts do's and don'ts and culture dues
talk about things that you care about
and you're passionate about and you know
don't try to jump on trends that you
don't care about but you're doing it
because it seemingly is a trend do's and
don'ts in the workplace do
deploy kind Candor but also deploy A
system that eliminates cancerous
individuals don't don't look the
underway when somebody's contributing to
your bottom line but they're destroying
your culture okay do's and don'ts when
it comes to social media dues really
learn it and do it yourself until you
really understand it don't don't
Outsource it to your 17 year old niece
because she's 17. do's and don'ts when
it comes to AI metaverse nfts new tech
dudes stay curious and answer maybe
every time you hear something new and
crazy don't use fear to say no and put
your head in the sand like you're an
ostrich Gary vaynerchuk thank you so
much for being on the show thanks Maha
appreciate it
foreign